[Musique]
bonjour Laurent
et Gabriel
chanteuse Alfortville
bonjour Laurent bonjour Gabriel
[Musique]
je suis un fou que je suis en route
tu as bien mangé
ce weekend
tu as une toute petite balle de
ping-pong
Eric en France on peut se balader dans
la commune d'Amboise ou dans la commune
de trouilles
pour être je dirais la trouille c'est la
commune d'angoisse non non
c'est la commune d'angoisse
c'est vers ça que je veux que vous
alliez
bravo parce que vous avez réussi à bien
un cercueil unique
eric est entrepreneur de pompes funèbres
depuis quelques mois il propose des
modèles personnalisés car les clients
posent souvent la même question la
première chose qui est demandé c'est
vraiment
avez-vous autre chose à nous proposer
que le cercueil classique le cercueil
personnalisé fait partie du rite
funéraire au Ghana ou le défunt peut
faire son dernier voyage dans un avion
ou une noix de coco
[Musique]
vous pouvez opter pour des obsèques plus
écolos c'est avec un cercueil par
exemple à base de carton ça fait un peu
de cheap ça se décompose dans un carton
c'est pas possible pardon accompagner
les morts vers leur dernière demeure à
bicyclette après tout pourquoi pas
désormais on peut transporter les morts
sur les pistes cyclables Isabelle
Plumereau a trouvé la bonne idée pour
enterrer écolo elle a fait assembler ce
triporteur
c'est un vrai plus à mon avis vraiment
de pouvoir adapter sa vitesse ne pas
faire de bruit ne pas avoir de
vibrations ne pas avoir de gaz
d'échappement je pense que c'est
vraiment un plus pour les convois il y a
même une technique d'inhumation qui
transforme le rapidement le corps humain
en compost pour le mettre ensuite dans
le jardin alors attention c'est autorisé
non mais c'est pas une blague c'est
autorisé dans certains États américains
c'est évidemment complètement interdit
en France mais l'idée c'est que le corps
se décompose en quelques mois et
qu'ensuite on peut l'utiliser comme
compost
qui se fait en matière de consommation
Halloween ou pas on a le droit de
laisser nos toiles d'araignées là où
elles sont on a le droit de les regarder
de les aimer parce qu'une vie ne se rate
pas Marie non elle ne se réussit pas non
plus elle se vit voilà oh là là Sénèque
bravo Victor inflation atteint un
nouveau niveau record dans la zone euro
avec plus 10,7% sur un an en octobre en
France je rappelle que nous sommes à
6,2% de hausse cette hausse des prix
alimentaire et parmi les plus
douloureuses d'autant qu'elle est loin
d'être terminée
c'est ce que je craignais
[Rires]
c'est par rectal il se mesure sur le
terrain caca
[Applaudissements]
les prix des produits alimentaires
augmentent à toute vitesse plus 14,5%
sur les produits laitiers plus son
ennemi pour cent pour l'épicerie ou
encore 6% pour les boissons
une inflation inévitable selon les
industriels de l'agroalimentaire
j'aimerais bien être de gauche
j'adorerais mais il faut des qualités
humaines un peu supérieures
ouverture à l'autre
partage
Laurent Ruquier si vous croisez ce genre
d'individu au look un probable et à la
démarche déterminée pas de panique il
s'agit probablement d'un adepte du
balancier gachallenge un défi pour
parodier la marque de luxe qui défilait
après défilé repousse les limites des
internautes entre les collections
présentées dans la boue et les sacs
poubelles en cuir vendu 1400 euros la
toile a de quoi s'amuser c'est peut-être
même les faire rechercher par Balenciaga
et l'homme de droite c'est simplement
pour Ruquier qui est pas quand même
c'est pas Guy Debord ils aiment beaucoup
Laurent
non mais j'aime beaucoup Ruquier mais
c'est pas non plus un philosophe c'est
il met de la bonne humeur et c'est pas
rien
et on ramasse tout de suite encore
c'est pas grave
[Musique]
bonsoir à la une de ce
[Rires]